يتخلص من لونه ويصبح كالزجاج هكذا ينام
الضفدع الزجاج ليحمي نفسه من الاعداء
اثناء النوم مجله الساينس العلميه نشرت
بحثا يشرح كيفيه ازاله هذا الضفدع لونه
حيث يخبئ نسبه الاكبر من خلايا الدم
الحمراء في كبده اثناء النوم ما يجعله
يكتسب صفه الشفافيه التصوير الضوئي لخلايا
الدم الحمراء لهذه الضفادع الزجاجيه اظهر
انها تزيد شفافيتها مرتين الى ثلاث مرات
عن طريق ازاله نحو 89% من خلايا الدم
الحمراء من الدوره الدمويه
وتعبئتها داخل الكبد وعندما يستيقظ تتدفق
خلايا الدم الحمراء بسرعه الى دوره
الدمويه والامر الغريب هو قدره الضفدع على
البقاء على قيد الحياه لفترات طويله من
دون حدوث جلطه في ظل تخزين معظم خلايا
الدم الحمراء في كبده
[موسيقى]